good morning believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
and I believe in your potential and I
want to see that come out to help you go
off and find that amazing thing inside
you unleash it out into the world I
started to believe life series to try to
tackle some more personal issues
personal development topics that
hopefully if you can apply it to your
life you will be unstoppable
so today we're gonna look at how to get
unstuck and as always guys as you're
watching if you hear something that
really resonates with you please leave
it in comments below and put quotes
around us so other people can be
inspired and when you write it down it's
much more likely to stick with yourself
as well enjoy
[Music]
we've all had that experience where it
just seems that we're not moving we're
holding on or where no matter what we do
it doesn't seem to be advancing us this
is what we call the experience of this
duck of not being able to move for
manifests or Express or experience that
which we desire to do being stuck is
both a mental experience an emotional
experience and sometimes a physical
experience and there are three reasons
that we get stuck
number one we really don't know who we
are when you don't know who you are you
don't know what you are capable of and
you get stuck in your limited
perceptions of yourself and reality
number two when you don't want to find
out who you are and you won't take the
risk to push yourself beyond what you
know and when you are stuck on your
story stuck on your sadness just stuck
on being stuck you don't want to know
who you are so you won't push yourself
you'll stay where it's comfortable
you'll stay where it's familiar boy will
you be stuck and the other reason that
we get stuck is because we live down to
other people's expectations of us how
many times have we been told as children
you can't do that don't do that
you can't do that you won't do that they
won't let me and we believe that and we
stay stuck
people suffer cuz they obsess about
themselves what they're losing what
they're missing out on what they'll
never have and it's not true it's only
true cuz you're letting your head take
over instead of your body and your heart
well anybody who's plateaued in their
job or stocker says they don't know what
to do and they say you know what am I
gonna do you'll never get the answer
from that state of mind if you're angry
if you're pissed off if you're
frustrated if you're bored you're not
your brains not gonna come up with same
answers as if you're feeling inspired or
hungry the first way to break out of it
is to feed that mind I made a goal that
said I'm gonna read an hour dad not the
newspaper something you know somebody's
biography so I could realize that the
most successful people on earth have
been through hell you know and how they
did it learning their strategies or
something on philosophy or strategy or
physiology I mean the second thing I did
is I realized that my fear was taking
over right fear is physical
so is courage it's also physical you
feel that sense of power or certainty in
your body so what I did is I trained
myself every day even if it was only ten
minutes to do something incredibly
intense physically when all that blood
is rushing to your body and that force
of will is coming out of you it changes
the way you feel mentally emotionally
and it changes your performance and then
the third thing I decided I needed to do
was to really be crystal clear about
what I wanted what was my goal and who's
a role model I could learn from and then
finally fourth thing was not to wait -
my life was weldin if I want to stop
being depressed then you stop focusing
on myself take back control by giving to
someone else who needs it more than you
you have no money you can walk down and
feed somebody at the local soup kitchen
and I promise you you will realize you
have no problems work out read and fill
your mind get clear your goal and some
great role models and go help somebody
right now and suddenly you'll realize
you have no problem certainly not
problems that are not solvable you may
have forgotten the truth which is you
have a hero inside of you when you were
a little kid you wanted to change the
world when you were a little child you
had these this visceral connection with
these lofty dreams and then what happens
is the world gives us this programming
and this messaging which is be average
don't dream too big be like everyone
else don't trust your instinct anymore
stop thinking outside of the ball
box don't dare you will be hurt and if
you start getting this kind of messaging
and this kind of conditioning from the
world around you everyday then you end
up where you might be today you might be
25 or you might be 30 you might be 17
you might be 70 and you'll have
forgotten that deep inside of you lives
a hero who wants to do something great
with your life who wants to inspire
other people who wants to do creative
work who wants to bring a sparkle in
your eye who wants to build a beautiful
life who wants to have some fun who
wants to change the world and I don't
know if this is resonating with you I'm
just speaking from the heart but
wherever you are on the planet you have
a hero inside you may have forgotten it
you may not tend to that hero maybe
you're so numbed out that you've
forgotten who you truly are and I just
want to humbly lovingly respectfully and
hopefully bravely reminds you that the
fact that you are alive today means you
are someone special the fact that you
are alive today means there is a mighty
call on your life to do something with
the rest of your life ask for what you
want this is how you get unstuck ask for
what you want most of us are stuck
because we're accepting what comes along
and we don't have the hoods for the
Hornets the nerve the guts or whatever
to ask for what we want and ask for what
you want being willing together know
being willing together no but then
having a clear idea vision of what
you're gonna do about it finally get a
vision a vision will pull you out of the
story don't be walking around I don't
know what I want I don't know where to
order
I want to open an ice cream parlor I
want to wake up every more the vision
will pull you forward tell the truth say
what you want ask for what you want get
a vision division of what you [ __ ]
that's it now I don't have anything else
to say like all of us have experienced
some tragedy and if we haven't we will
and you can even let it destroy your
life or you can build upon it you can
permit it to let you let it hold you
down or you can decide I'm not going to
let that happen to me I'm bigger than
this make a declaration to yourself
declare all-out war that you're going to
get out of this rut I don't care how
good you are to care how talented you
are I don't care how much you work on
yourself there sometimes when things
aren't going to go right they just I'm
not going to go right there are times
with anything that can't happen will
happen Murphy's Law will be knocking at
your door why I don't know why that's
called life and you have to deal with it
sometimes your life will be in a slump
just like sports some of the best
shooters can't hit baskets different
times and games they get in a slump do
they sit on the sidelines and say you
know I just did hit a basket today no
they continue to execute I suggest to
you that if you are facing a challenge
don't stop
stay busy work your plan continue to do
those things that you know that work for
you after you have evaluated yourself in
the situation you know weeds don't have
to have any encouragement to grow
you don't have to water them they don't
have to get sunshine they don't have to
have fertile ground they will grow
through the cracks of a sidewalk am i
right but if you want to grow orchids or
roses or any kind of exotic flowers
there are special processes and
procedures you must go through
well by the same token you don't have to
force yourself or motivate yourself to
think negatively to be depressed to hate
somebody to want revenge you want to get
back at somebody to beat yourself up
over the head to feel loaded with guilt
you don't have to make any effort to do
that your mind is on automatic it will
do that by itself but if you want to
begin to move into your own personal
greatness if you want to begin to really
enjoy a happy successful healthy life
you've got to be willing to go against
the tide you've got to be willing to
harness your will and say in spite of
this I'm in control here I'm not gonna
let this get me down I'm not gonna let
this destroy me I'm coming back and I'll
be stronger and better because of it you
have got to make a declaration that this
is what you stand for you're standing up
for your dreams you're standing up for
peace of mind you're standing up for
health you want it and you're gonna go
all out to have it it's not going to be
easy
when you want to change it's not easy if
it were in fact easy everybody to do it
but if you're serious you'll go all out
you got to just simplify you got I would
look at what is the one thing that if I
focused on that that would really have a
big impact and have a ripple effect
because once you start making progress
on one thing and you're getting some
results it bleeds into everything else
you're doing once you're confident
you're more confident in a business deal
you become more confident your personal
life as well it bleeds through
everything and so I'd be looking at okay
there's a thousand things that you have
to do what's the one sing the most
important thing that you fixed this
it'll not only help that one situation
but everything
as well and then focus on doing that and
eliminate the distractions around him so
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what
did you think of this video what are you
going to take from this and immediately
apply it somehow into your life or your
business I would love to hear your
thoughts please leave it down in the
comments below I also want to give a
quick shout out to Anthony Avena Anthony
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word and doing the
review on your blog I really appreciate
the support man and I'm so glad you
enjoyed the book so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love guys
I'll see you soon the most important
word ever if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple that would be like a
little beacon hey believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details
[Music]